good morning believe nation my name is
Alex and my one word is belong and I
believe that the world would be a better
place if more people felt that they
belong to help you on your journey
today's messages do your research over
to you Robert Kiyosaki everyone says
finding good real estate is hard when
you're getting started what's the value
of good network and good partnerships
well I'll say it again in 1973 I came
back from Vietnam and I was a pilot out
there and I took a real estate course
there was $385 three days long and
that's a lot of money back then I was
only making $500 a month so 385 was all
I had and the instructor then the
program said to me he said what did the
whole class full of 30 of us he says
your education begins now that you leave
the class even get educated while the
class so his assignment was that
everybody have 30 of us with the Parapan
team get up in teams to two or three to
a team and went to look at a 100
properties in 90 days and he says don't
buy anything just look at a hundred
properties doing evaluation of each
property write-up write a short blurb
about it why it's good why it's bad and
it's at the end of 90 days and a hundred
properties then you make up your mind if
you're going to buy something he says if
you haven't found one property in a
hundred a hundred deals you start again
you know you start again another hundred
and that's what most that's why most
people are not rich they're not willing
to go through that process of looking at
a hundred deals to find one deal and
this sometimes in the you and I know you
look at a lot of frogs to find one
princess you know but when you find that
one princess everybody goes oh well how
do you get so lucky
well I looked at a lot of dirt dirt dogs
out there you know and that's like
anything in life you don't marry the
man or woman you meet hopefully a kiss a
couple of what Mina before you do put
the time in to know your facts instead
of just always acting and reacting in
life for me well originally I wanted to
be a marriage counselor and before I'd
made that decision to go into studying
psychology University I did a bunch of
research I even talked to therapists
when I was going through university I
realize you know what it's not quite
right for me so I wanted to become a cop
so what I started doing I went to a
police station nearby started asking
questions and time I saw cops I would
approach them and ask them questions
about their career of what they feel
about it how are they enjoying it what's
the work-life balance all that kind of
stuff in all the major decisions in my
life for my career choices even though I
change it drastically from one to
another I always made sure that before I
jump in I go and I get all the
information not only online in books but
from people who are doing the job this
let me get insight into the world of
that job so when I went from wanting to
be a cop to going into sales I did
research looking at different companies
what are the best companies to work for
what did they look for what should be on
my resume what kind of money do they
make I went to talk to salespeople
I didn't just jump in ultimately right
now I'm in my current position as
director of operations of Toronto and
salsa I love it the path to success and
the path to feeling fulfilled in life is
never a straight path for most people
it's not and just because I didn't do
exactly the thing that I researched
initially which is being a marriage
counselor that's not the point
the point is your time is valuable and
yes you do need to get the experience
you shouldn't just sit on your couch
always planning you need to take action
but when you're taking action it's
important to have your facts and to be
knowledgeable about the thing you're
wanting to invest time into and then
once you get into it then you can make a
sound decision open your eyes go do the
research invest time into the thing that
ultimately can make you happy so the
question of the day is what's a decision
you're sitting on right now that if you
did a little more
search into you can get it clear yes or
no and what you should do I also want to
give a quick shout out to Robbie will
Robbie thank you so much for purchasing
a copy of evans book your one word it
really means a lot to us thank you so
much again for watching we believe in
you and we hope you can seem to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word
is and we'll see you tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso and we'll
see another episod and we'll see you
again in another episode of coffee sense
with Alex Jess Alex taking over whoo I
also want to give a clock of quack quack
quack quack quack here and a quack quack
there okay
unfortunately our society's gotten so
lazy in their research it's it's
unfortunate especially where I'm in here
in the United States our educational
system has gotten so bad and people are
so lazy and I don't mean to mean speak
to everybody but you know there's a very
big lazy culture right now where people
won't take the time they don't even read
a book on their topic like Oh a whole
book you know they'll read a blog
article and pretended this enough it's
like no you know what the highest
performers they're always researching
and they're doing real research I mean
they don't read one book on the top if
they read seven you know they don't
interview one person they interview a
person a week they don't read one blog
post they read them print them out
highlight them create binders I mean if
you want to become world-class you got
to know what is else is out there what
other lessons people have learned you
can't keep inventing the wheel you gotta
know someone else has already figured
this out research them stand on their
shoulders you know what a lot of people
don't understand is Einstein while he
was a genius he also was prolific in the
amount of research he did on on theories
that have already been proven and where
their holes might be he was constantly
researching everything not just putting
new ideas into play he was busting up on
old ideas and standing on the shoulders
of giants who'd already made major
breakthroughs that now he could apply in
new areas with new insights new metaphor
new discovery you got to get back into
reading and understanding and paying
attention yeah I read the books the
minute I got the part I went and went
and bought all of them and read them
mainly out of curiosity about what might
be happening also out of I felt I had a
source material there and whenever I've
got a source material I feel that for me
anyway I need to look at all information
I can gather about that fictional
character if you read the first
description of John it informed I think
I I think I for my audition I bought the
book read the first description of John
read a bit to get an idea of it and then
went in with that but it's it's already
in the book that he's quiet he's quite
sort of dour in a way he's he's he's
like the black sheep
there was it within that first paragraph
about who he was and what his is sort of
essence was like gave me that first sort
of tap into how I should how I should do
that first audition and then that
template stays with you for six years of
who what character you've made that's
the way I if I have something like that
to go on the way I work is I'll look at
exactly what the writer or these writers
or the right over the book thinks this
person is if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you up or that would be like a
little beacon they believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details